so I'm working on a Horror history
script about a villain who has sparked a
lot of debate among fans with many
people taking this villain's side and
saying that this person was actually
Justified I'm not ready to say who that
person is yet but it got me thinking are
there any villains who are actually
doing the right thing so I put up a post
asking my audience for input challenging
you guys to name a villain who was in
the right and I also spent the day
thinking about it and basically decided
uh no if they were in the right then
they wouldn't be considered the villain
right but after mulling this over a
little bit further I do think that there
may be a couple villains who qualify to
find out who stick around rounds to the
end of this video